[Music]
it was a scene of catastrophic
carnage a busy tram full of commuters
derailed with devastating consequences
these are the seven who died that day
their families have waited over four
years to find out why
we didn't even get to say goodbye that's
that's the hardest thing
is we didn't get to say goodbye
danielle's grandad philip logan was a
bricklayer
that morning it was raining and he
almost stayed at home
i just wish that he'd stuck to his guns
and not got on that tram that morning
but he went to work he went to work and
he didn't even make it to work
investigators said the crash was fast
and violent
their analysis shows the tram overturned
because it went too quickly around this
bend
here's what happened the tram set off
just before
6 am exiting the sandylands tunnels it
was going 48 miles an hour
within the 50 speed limit just before
the corner that limit drops to 12 miles
an hour but the tram was doing
45 nearly four times the speed limit
seconds later it derailed reports
concluded
the driver was probably in a micro sleep
at the time
this is where the tram overturned it was
something
nobody ever expected to happen despite
the fact there have been
previous late-breaking incidents at this
exact spot
including one just 10 days before the
accident
changes have been made there's extra
signage
a driver alertness system and automatic
brakes if trams speed
but the families feel frustrated the
inquest didn't dig
deeper with every single breath
that i have i'm never going to let this
lie
that man and those six other people
deserve justice
their lives have already been lost they
don't they don't get to continue their
life and their journeys
but i do those left behind
are struggling to move forward their
heartbreak and hunt for answers
continues laura bundock sky news